Shakeel ins four teams river here see
how the Seahawks hey you're watching
star [ __ ] cut we're gonna be choosing
that category here it's gonna be one to
start once a bench and want to cook Wow
we're gonna start Remember the Titans
we're going to [ __ ] Friday Night Lights
and we're gonna cut Ruby yeah go go
gotta go sorry
turn the front of your iPad turn the
iPad gotta go hey I thought you going
with tough one and so he doesn't look
bad I'm gonna agree with well I'm gonna
shut off wait whoa hey this is my
question
okay oh wait she Keene City centric you
i'ma start call of duty I'm a banshee
today because I recently did that you
know I'm a cup man
I've had enough football already you
know I Bobby tonnison I gotta ask this
for him repeat it
you're gonna start call of duty he's
gonna bring GTA yo and he's gonna cut
man bring him back cut man again it's on
the iPad yep turn them in yup tell y'all
fat in man oh we we are going to start
South Park
indeed we are going to [ __ ] Ricky Moore
getting cut are we gonna bench I think
she was right how to make sure they had
his time at his moment so we'll be more
than funny though but spongebob just I
grew up more to it so definitely [ __ ]
punch sorry Ricky board against South
Park Josh just human for all the
language out there and we'll watch out
for it but I still love it that's how
far he's a baby
I love the South Park Carter 3 ok I'm a
starter Carter 3 I'm a [ __ ] get rich or
die trying' and I'm a cut
I forgot to laugh yeah last word you
forgot guys back there because we are we
grew up to the Carter three and just
dumb chance that he had it just had a
whole club rockin Eve if you want to
have the whole club rocket I'll talk
about warm-ups I'm talking about pre
games I'll talk about the anywhere just
sitting inside a dorm room or anything
anybody play this on everybody go first
secular oh wait we always been fair no
no way so actually get a chance to meet
for the first time I think what you got
dressed down so always been fans always
been fast the moonwalk is definitely
starting you see week I will bench the
Carlton and I will cut the dougie
only because my brother can do it that's
good and I did it really well but we
both ain't doing it at the same they
don't look right so I gotta cut the day
because him I don't know why he said
that
go ahead do Doug yeah yeah yeah on a
camera I can't do it but like one person
who said we're really cool so you sure I
couldn't go the world I won't do a dance
that I could as a point that I cut it so
I won't have to do it but you just
literally turn your high-paying which
was a turn y'all pansy I can't coach
he's just scared to dougie he's gonna
bring the dougie back up this is
Shekinah shake Hill Griffin and this
will star bench cut